salut voila la troisième vidéo sur la
rationalité et pour le coup je vous
déconseille de commencer ici il faut
vraiment aller voir les des premières
pour comprendre ce qui est en jeu ce
qu'on va explorer maintenant c'est la
fonction des croyances disons ceci il ya
des choses que notamment pour vrai
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
il ya différentes manières de décrire ce
qui est en jeu quand on dit qu'une chose
est vraie je suis moi même séduit par la
proche pragmatiste mais on va pas se
lancer là dedans maintenant ce sera pour
une autre vidéo pour simplifier disons
ceci intuitivement croire qu'une chose
est vraie c'est croire qu'elle
correspond à la réalité si je tiens pour
vrai qu'il ya un arbre devant moi c'est
que je pense qu'il ya réellement un
arbre devant moi que la paix partie de
la réalité
on distingue dont les choses qui
composent la réalité des choses
imaginez affective etc on pourrait faire
de la métaphysique et débattre du statut
à accorder aux entités de la fiction
mais ce n'est pas le cas ce qu'il faut
retenir c'est que l'ensemble des choses
que nous tenons pour ré c'est à dire
l'ensemble des choses réelles
cet ensemble composé une image du monde
cette image c'est un peu comme une carte
nous sommes des cartographes parce que
nous faisons une image du monde qui est
censé correspondre à la réalité
nous organisons que nous le voulions ou
non nos croyances sur le monde
en représentation et il faut le
souligner c'est très important celle-ci
se veulent cohérente
ça veut dire qu'on reconnaît que la
contradiction est problématique c'est
vrai pour les faits comme on le disait
avec l'exemple de la gravité ou de l'eau
qui mouille mais c'est vrai aussi pour
les valeurs si on est contre
l'avortement parce qu'on se dit pro life
parce qu'on pense qu'il est toujours
immorale de tuer il serait logique
d'être aussi contre la peine de mort et
aux états unis ce n'est pas toujours le
cas
donc si on dit qu'on se fait une image
du monde qui se veut juste et cohérente
cela veut dire que les éléments qui
composent d'image prétendre représenter
fidèlement la réalité est qu'il n'y a
pas entre eux de conflit trop important
ou irrésolu une croyance peut être plus
ou moins fiables et des croyances
peuvent être plus ou moins compatibles
entre elles si on dit que nos présences
dessiner une carte du monde on pourrait
distinguer trois critères la fiabilité
qu'ils relatifs à la fidélité de la
carte la cohérence ce qui est relatif à
la constance et la pertinence
ce qui est relatif au contenu je ne
crois pas qu'il y ait beaucoup de débats
sur les deux premiers critères
c'est le troisième qui est plus délicat
comment juger qu'une idée une
représentation à un point de vue est
intéressant ce n'est pas facile à dire
c'est qu'il faut souligner la relative
indépendance de ce critère une carte
peut être pertinente même en étant
imparfaite du point de vue des critères
1 et 2
parfois on fait comme si la carte
n'était porteuse d'aucune information
pertinente simplement parce qu'elle
présente une erreur de logique alors que
ça ne suffit pas à discréditer une
proposition il ya une blague pour ça
c'est pas parce que je suis
hypocondriaque que je suis pas vraiment
malade il faut parfois distinguer les
erreurs de raisonnement de ces contenus
un hypocondriaque a peut-être un
traitement irrationnelle et paranoid de
ses sensations cela n'empêche pas qu'ils
puissent effectivement décrire une
situation pathologique autre que celle
de son hypocondrie j'entends quand on
évalue une carte c'est à dire en somme
l'idée du monde que ce fait quelqu'un il
vaut mieux ne pas oublier ces critères
là surtout le troisième quand on est
adepte de l'esprit critique et qu'on
peut avoir tendance à ne s'occuper que
des rouages de la pensée sans voir
l'intérêt que peut présenter le
mécanisme dans son ensemble on a
tendance à l'oublier parce que c'est le
plus difficile à saisir
jeudi quand on évalue une carte la
première carte à évaluer c'est bien sûr
la sienne donc on commence par évaluer
la fiabilité des croyances qui composent
notre carte un premier truc qu'on peut
remarquer c'est que notre degré de
certitude vis-à-vis de chaque présence
varie en fonction de plusieurs critères
ce qui renvoie au tableau la vidéo
précédente est elle plutôt singes ou
plutôt complexe pour totem sur moi-même
sur le monde sur des faits un terry
fiables sur ce qui est bien ou mal etc
il est normal d'être davantage certains
d'une croyance relative à une réalité
factuelle simple que d'une présence
relative un devoir moral ça suppose que
notre carnet non pas homogène et puis
tout cela dépend aussi de notre deuxième
expertise relativement au domaine auquel
appartient la croyance si j'ai passé du
temps à étudier une question je serai
davantage certain que si je les ai à
peine effleuré ont fait face à un
problème classique c'est quoi un expert
en théorie c'est quelqu'un qui connaît
mieux quelque chose que la plupart des
gens mais du coup il faut comprendre que
plus le domaine est petit plus
l'expertisé crédible quelqu'un se
présente comme un expert de l'histoire
du label actuelle qui n'a duré que deux
ans et publié seulement une cinquantaine
de disques c'est crédible quelqu'un qui
se présente comme un expert de toute la
musique des années 70 c'est un peu moins
crédible quelqu'un qui se présente comme
un expert de toute la musique du xxème
siècle c est pas crédible du tout on
pourrait être tenté de dire qu'un expert
ça n'existe pas ce qui existe c'est une
opinion expertes
c'est à dire une opinion travailler et
qui est vous serez adoubé par ceux qui
travaillent et connaissent le sujet une
opinion experte en fait c'est très rare
que ce soit surprenant
en général ça va dans le sens de ce
qu'on sait déjà et ça ne concerne
vraiment que les détails il est donc
pertinent de faire appel à l'opinion
expert pour le détail mais moins pour
juger la carte dans son ensemble il n'y
a pas d' expertise de la pensée total ça
c'est ce que propose des philosophes et
ils font rarement consensus pour ce qui
est de leur vision du monde
il est très difficile qui plus est
d'avoir du recul sur son expertise
quelqu'un peut être expert d'un domaine
sans se rendre compte que sa méthode de
travail est orienté pour le découvrir il
en a besoin d'un expert en méthode de
travail mais lui aurait besoin d'une
expertise encore plus vaste sur le sens
de l'anc est en général et c'est la cata
deviennent les philosophes et l'absence
de consensus qui va avec est rationnel
ça suppose à mon sens ne jamais perdre
de vue cette difficulté pour atteindre
le degré de certitude liées à
l'expertisé
il faut se limiter à un champ d'étude
restreint et une méthodologie analytique
qui ne permet pas au moins dans le même
temps une vue d'ensemble
l'individu rationnelle doit garder à
l'esprit ces deux dimensions ce qu'on
pourrait appeler de l'analyse factuelle
d'une part et la production de 100
autres par cette distinction fait écho à
celle des croyances et des désirs elle
nous permet de situer le travail et ses
méthodes
si l'on interroge son travail qu'en
fonction de sa précision factuelle on
est aveugle à son sens on avance dans
une direction sans savoir laquelle on
suit son désir sans avoir mis en
perspective on ne voit pas qu'il existe
un désir de décrire le réel
un désir de réalité qui détermine notre
travail de l'autre côté si on ne cherche
pas à baliser sa démarche avec un
minimum d'esprit critique si on ne
confond pas sa pensée au fait celle-ci
risque d'impliquer une confusion de la
réalité avec ses désirs
n'est ce pas là en quelque sorte le sens
d sign soir d'un côté on reproche aux
études sur le genre est la pensée
postcoloniale intersectionnelle ou post
moderne de n'être qu'une spéculation
fantasmes et de l'autre on reproche à la
prochaine à l'éthique de manquer tout ce
qui donne du sens à l'existence c'est à
dire tout ce qui fait que l'on se veut
dire quelque chose
le désir dans son sens le plus fort
c'est schématique bien sûr mais
peut-être que ça peut éclairer le débat
quand même donc justement quid du désir
et bien déjà
reconnaissons que nous avons tous des
désirs je crois d'ailleurs que même pire
on avait des désirs ses trucs qu'on veut
on associe souvent ça des objectifs
aussi bien je veux manger cette pomme je
veux devenir médecin je veux rêver de
jean claude van damme l'année prochaine
je veux avoir du succès sur youtube
on prétendait se dire qu'il ya deux ans
je distincts d'écrire ou faire une carte
et atteindre son objectif
mais il faut insister sur le lien entre
les deux points
ne pas croire qu'on peut les traiter
séparément nos croyances dépendent de
nos désirs et nos désirs dépendent de
nos croyances
cette interconnexion est fondamentale et
ne doit pas être laissée de côté
désirer quelque chose et une présence
factuel on tient pour vrai qu'il vaut
mieux obtenir l'objet du désir
peut-être parce qu il nous rendra plus
heureux ou en tout cas parce qu'il aura
tel ou tel effet et notre compréhension
du réel est toujours lié à des désirs
nous ne prenons pas le monde au gré des
rencontres suivant le hasard comme des
robots neutre nous nous orientons notre
environnement en fonction de ce qui est
identifié comme bénéfique et nuisibles
vouloir comprendre comment fonctionne
une cellule ne répondent pas aux mêmes
désirs que de vouloir comprendre comment
fonctionne la psyché on vise certaines
connaissances on travaille le
raisonnement en fonction de ce qui
stimule notre curiosité de ce qui nous
intéresse c'est ce qui nous sommes plus
important ce qui correspond à nos
valeurs
il est absurde d'imaginer que notre
représentation du monde pourrait
s'établir indépendamment de notre
système de valeurs
certains seront tentés de répondre mais
c'est pourtant bien l'objectif que se
donne les sciences dites dures elles ne
sont pas orientés par des valeurs si
bien sûr mais c'est manqué un pas de
recul
l'objectif de neutralité répond à une
valeur le choix de la méthode à employer
pour cartographier est née une valeur je
ne dis pas que tout se vaut et je ne nie
d'ailleurs pas la pertinence et
l'intérêt de la valeur à l'origine de
cet objectif de neutralité la méthode
scientifique parce qu'elle élimine
autant que possible et biais culturel
permet l'élaboration d'un savoir solide
est incroyablement efficace
elle représente évidemment un atout
fondamental pour le développement de
l'espèce
je demande simplement si elle ne
gagnerait pas être davantage consciente
du système de valeurs qui la soutient de
la totalité à laquelle elle participe je
souligne simplement
dès que quelque chose a de l'importance
pour nous c'est que ça déborde la pure
description on pourrait le dire ainsi la
philosophie a besoin des sciences mais
les sciences ont également besoin de
philosophie l'activité de cartographes
et comme toute activité motivée par des
besoins et des désirs et donc une
approche rationnelle consiste à mesurer
le rôle que jouent ces besoins et désirs
dans l'émergence de nos croyances et
dans notre manière de les évaluer si on
s'accorde à dire que la carte représente
l'ensemble de nos croyances relatives à
ce qui existe à ce qui n'existe pas à ce
qu'il vaut mieux faire ou ne pas faire
on pourrait dire que notre expérience
consciente est une image ou une
expression de la carte que nous sommes
la carte
en un sens je suis la carte et la carte
et le monde
dire que je suis là car tu ne peux pas
dire que la carte dépend de la volonté 1
cela veut dire que tout ce que je pense
et ressent et sur la carte et donc que
je n'aurais jamais accès à autre chose
que la carte qu'à chaque instant où je
change la carte change aussi que chaque
changement de la carte est un changement
de la personne une modification
inconsciente peut avoir des effets sur
l'expérience consciente changé son
rapport à une croyance peut transformer
nos affects associé à une chose tout
bêtement mon amour pour une personne
dépend de ce que je crois qu'elle est et
dans le même sens ce que je crois
qu'elle est dépend de mon amour pour
elle pour rappel on a dit que être
rationnel c'est faire du mieux qu'on
peut avec ce qu'on a
donc on ne s'occupe pas directement de
vérité on s'occupe de croyance de désir
et du lien entre les deux si ma carte
est la réalité est le monde au sens où
comme on disait
l'expérience consciente et le produit du
corps donc de la matière si ma garde à
l'expression de ce qu'on tient
d'habitude pour ce qui est en face cela
veut dire que tout ce que je vis est le
monde tout ce que j'appelle monde est
sur la carte tout ce qui est sur la
carte composent le monde mais ça ne veut
pas dire que tout se vaut ça veut dire
que pour différencier les valeurs il
faut identifier le point de vue par
exemple
du point de vue de ma survie toutes mes
perceptions ne se valent pas j'ai
intérêt à voir qu'il y à un ours devant
moi et non un gentil éléphants roses ça
fait écho à la frisbie pragmatiste je
ferai une vidéo spécifiquement la subit
un taux pour un pragmatiste tous
différents théorique doit faire une
différence pratique donc une croyance et
interrogés selon ces effets réels dans
l'expérience et cela veut dire aussi
qu'il n'est pas très rationnel de
critiquer une idée si l'on n'a pas
adopté au moins un certain temps il faut
éprouver ce qu'implique une hypothèse
donc la mettre à l'épreuve pour savoir
ce qu'elle veut si on ne fait pas assez
d'efforts on risque de se complaire dans
une lecture purement verbal de la pensée
jugeant les raisonnements en fonction de
leur forme et non de ce qu'ils
permettent
il ne faut pas perdre de vue la
différence qu'une pensée introduit dans
l'expérience dans la vie elle-même
on peut dire que nos objectifs sont
trésor et que la réussite de notre quête
dépend donc de la qualité de la carte
il ya plein de moments où la fiabilité
de la carte dépend de sa concordance
avec celle des autres
par exemple j'ai intérêt à penser que
lorsque le feu est rouge cela veut
vraiment dire qu'il faut s'arrêter
j'ai intérêt à penser que le soleil se
lèvera demain sinon je risque de passer
une journée angoissante mais c'est vrai
jusqu'à un certain point
parfois j'ai intérêt à prendre une sorte
de marge vis-à-vis de l'activité qui
prétend reproduire fidèlement le
territoire on prend d'ailleurs tous
cette marche toute la journée sans s'en
rendre compte
la perception est une hallucination
pratique nous ne voyons pas la réalité
nous voyons une simplification de la
réalité qui c'est un autre désir de
survie si c'est vrai de la perception on
peut imaginer que ces présents dans les
couches les plus complexes de notre
rapport à l'existence par exemple nous
faisons une confusion entre la réalité
et nos désirs
quand nous attribuons une valeur et une
chose parce que nous le désirons c'est
la fameuse phrase de spinoza qu'on avait
évoqué dans la vidéo sur la place
d'autrui dans notre histoire personnelle
nous croyons voir une chose bonne en soi
dont la valeur ne dépend pas de nous
comme si le monde était composée
d'éléments bons et mauvais nous ne
voyons pas que la valeur des objets ou
des expériences varie selon les
situations et les objectifs
nous projetons une valeur sûre la chose
en fonction de notre désir ou de nos
besoins
aussi nous n'avons pas l'intuition que
le monde pourrait ressembler à autre
chose si nous changions nos désirs une
bonne car le calice l'objectif et
identifie les meilleurs chemins pour y
parvenir sachant que meilleur chemin des
pendant que d'autres objectifs c'est le
lien entre la rationalité épistémique ou
l'art de faire des bonnes cartes et la
rationalité instrumentale ou l'art de
choisir les bons chemins et comme on
disait
ces deux dimensions sont liés atteindre
un objectif à un coût donc il faut se
demander si ça vaut le coup
c'est aussi ça à reconnaître
l'importance du désir certains
voudraient que le désir ne jouent pas de
rôle dans leur cartographie du monde
alors ils voient leur carte comme une
représentation neutre uniquement composé
d'informations neutres ce qui est une
illusion fomenté par le désir de n'être
pas biaisé par ses désirs
si être rationnel suppose de mettre à
l'épreuve ses croyances alors il faut
s'intéresser au rôle que jouent nos
désirs dans leur élaboration
ça semble très important pour comprendre
l'autre peut-être qu'on voit les choses
différemment parce qu'on a des désirs
différents la politique justement ça
pourrait être essayé de faire
correspondre les cartes entre elles
discutent et voir si on peut faire
converger les perspectives dans ma carte
c'est chiant si on peut agresser les
gens sans raison à badens la mienne
aussi
ok on interdit les agressions alain oui
oui on fait ça
dans ma carte c'est cool si j'ai tous
les droits ça ne marche pas dans ma
carte mais non plus bon ok ok
reconnaître que les désirs nous font
voir les choses différemment et décisif
dans le processus politique
tout simplement parce que notre rapport
au monde et notre conception de celui ci
dépend entièrement de sa propension à
satisfaire nos désirs par exemple on
pourrait remarquer que ceux qui sont le
plus réfractaire à l'idée de changer le
monde sont ceux pour qui le monde n'est
pas très hostile on défend le statu quo
quand le statu quo nous arrange plutôt
une question importante qu'on pourrait
se poser serait donc la suivante le
monde mais thil favorable s'il m'est
favorable je risque de penser
il est très bien comme il est voir si le
monde est ainsi c'est qu'il doit être
ainsi s'il n'aimait pas favorable je
risque de penser il faut changer les
choses la même chose m'apparaît légitime
dans un cas problématiques dans l'autre
c'est ce qu'on peut appeler une
perspective et c'est ce qu'on va
explorer un peu plus précisément dans la
prochaine vidéo
salut